quick question which one of these is a
hate symbol is it a the bowl haircut be
the number 12 or see the okay hand sign
[Music]
the answer is of course all of them
let's go through some more examples hey
remember this guy I've actually never
showed him properly on my channel but
most you probably know it's Pepe the
Frog pepper the Frog was a booming meme
from 2015 to 2016 everyone loved this
guy from what started in just a pretty
small comic book was adopted by the
internet to become the biggest meme of
that time celebrities were posting him
and what made Peppa so popular was that
he could be made into anything and the
fact that there were so many different
versions of Pepe became a meme in itself
Pepe practically became too popular and
versions of Pepe that should never have
been made was created which changed
things a lot but they were all of them
deceived for another
[Music]
urging racist ideology known as the
alt-right jr. for example he put this
image on his Instagram account it's a
meme of Pepe and for those of you who
don't know Pepe is a white nationalist
symbol are essentially nihilist who do
it for the law basically that means for
the heck of it racist anti-semitic and
overall just offensive
Pepe memes were spread across the
internet and the future of Pepe looked
bleak but there was some who resisted
some people fought back a movement
called hashtag save pepper was created
by Matt Fury hippies creator to try and
bring Pepe back to something positive
the internet tried to help even ADL try
to help but it was too late
Pepe was declared dead by mad fury and
in one of his comic strips we see Pepe
for the last time this of course hasn't
stopped Pepe from being used by normal
people or people with bad intentions but
Matt did what he had to do to distance
himself from what it had become it's a
kind of side story how hate triumphs but
Matt is still trying to save Pepe if you
want you can check out a Kickstarter
link in the description either way
people were ready to move on but from
the ashes of Pepe came something far
worse
the photo from the White House causing
controversy today the photo shows
President Trump posing with White House
interns at the president's request all
the young men and women give his
thumbs-up signature but look at the
intern in the back row he's making a
hand gesture that's quite different than
any of the others to some it appears to
symbolize white power the white power
signal is made with the right hand and
outstretched fingers that make a W and P
as in white power hold on we're not
seriously falling for this are we ah the
origin of the white power okay hand sign
was quickly traced back to 4chan the
idea was to create another hate symbol
like Pepe as a way to troll and to
create political discourse some people
took the bait obviously but it was also
at this time that the circle game was
again becoming popular online the basic
gist of the game is haha made you look
while making the okay sign underneath
your waist people mock just how stupid
the idea was some use it as an
opportunity to provoke but it was
obvious it was another Pepe and this
time there was solid proof that it was a
troll operation so people did the
responsible thing this time and declared
the okay sign wasn't a hate symbol we
can't verify tonight that the claim the
okay sign is a hate symbol is false but
it's never really that easy shortly
after the unthinkable happened
whether path or just attract install
we've actually started doing the okay
hand gesture is not okay
Blizzard with right to man it's just
doing it regular and as I was looking at
the camera he started to put the
universal sign on her shoulder and she's
been hot the incident happened while
former cub duh Glanville was on the air
for NBC Sports Chicago the man seated
behind him flashed an upside down okay
gesture which is said to be a symbol of
white power the broadcast cut to a
graphic with stats but the gesture was
seen for several seconds if the Cubs
actively working to track down that
person who made that gesture
[Music]
hello
it's me tired of editing this video I
keep saying the argument that well the
swastika was taken by the Nazis so
symbols do change meaning like it used
to mean the Sun or whatever it came from
Buddhism so yeah even if the okay symbol
mein used to mean okay these things
change the validity of it's changed
meaning is pointed towards white
supremacist now actually using it but of
course they're gonna use it unlike other
heat symbols this was given to them stop
making it so easy for these people like
white supremacists have use the sign why
the hell wouldn't they the problem with
these hate symbols is that there's
people who like to demonize other people
and there's people that like to troll
and these two just play into each other
perfectly they both get exactly what
they want from each other one gets a
reaction the other gets an outrage and
then you have normal people in in
between who's not even playing this game
that gets caught up in in it I'm not
saying that anyone that gets mad over
someone using this sign is part of some
outraged mob but there is a clear
culture or on getting upset it's it's
false virtue rewarded with likes we're
basically training ourselves to act like
this and to be clear I don't think
spamming the okay sign here look are you
mad now like that's not helping either
obviously if you look in the instances
that I showed logically the evidence
that they are signaling white power it's
so incredibly weak but he just doesn't
matter they did it try sitting like this
it is actually comfortable wait what was
her name again I forgot [ __ ] apparently
she's half Mexican half Polish Jewish
grandchild of a Holocaust survivor but
she was accused of flashing the white
power hand symbol circle game has been
used in news media before it's just a
way to see haha gotcha wall
not everyone is aware that it's been
co-opted by a small group of people and
they and they shouldn't no one should
know these things the guy flashing the
sign during the Blissett footage stepped
up even though there was no reason for
him to do so and explained yeah that was
me I actually had no idea it had any
other meaning the most recent incident
of this happening was the GRU costume
and Warner Brothers I got fired because
they discovered in their home video that
he made the okay hand sign even though
the child is doing it this as well
why the hell would someone symbol for
white power in a private home video who
we see signaling to the parents by
acting angry and upset over these things
you're giving validity to the symbol
it's supposed to be a dog whistle that's
how this is defended all we need to we
need to know about these things if it's
a dog whistle it's a goddamn megaphone
everyone gets called out on it on the
one hand it control Chola responds that
they can deny but it also can signal
their support for white supremacist
ideas so the argument is that you can
use it and then just say no I'm just do
you do in the okay sign so we need to
know about this so we can't allow white
supremacist to dog whistle to each other
when congratulations you're doing that
by making by accusing people that aren't
white supremacist of being white
supremacist you are helping white
supremacist I think that's what annoys
me so much about this whole thing it's
really not about what what's the best
outcome and I think when we don't care
about the outcome that's when we really
destroy ourselves here's what I need you
to do don't get upset about the hand
sign and don't spam it like oh I'm so
epically trolling you Oh God
oh no the thumb of one race Oh God
brofist have bye